Josh Duhamel ins with us the actor
transformers life as we know it safe
haven you got something coming up on USA
Network its we get do we get to the
bottom of who murdered Biggie and Tupac
yeah actually they've known for years I
these are 95 percent sure on on they
know for sure on Tupac they done 95
percent sure on Biggie we'll charges
ever be brought I don't think so
you know it's not about what you know
it's what you can prove and it would
cost way too much it would it if it's
doing consistent on who brings what
information you know mommy wants to talk
yes that that's been the key is you know
people say you know why aren't you
solving this you got to get people who
are willing to cooperate yeah and so
there's a lot of inconsistencies but
they know they have you know confessions
and by the way this a great actor josh
says he's playing Tupac in this year so
it's a little bit of a stretch because
Tupac was a short guy wasn't he also
charismatic yes oh it's good to see you
here's our poll question this our Paulie
you want to give Josh the new poll
question see how he responds since he's
a big-time actor whose career would you
want Clint Eastwood Sean Connery Gene
Hackman Harrison Ford Morgan Freeman a
whole body of work
Clint no doubt yeah because I love what
Clint's done as a director too I love
the dude I mean all those guys are great
I wish I had that deep bass that Morgan
Freeman has maybe I'll never happen here
but Harrison Ford Indiana Jones and then
star wars right he's been in some of the
biggest movies yeah in in history
have you met but Clint Eastwood oh yeah
several times yeah I play the little 3m
thing every year with him oh okay do you
find him intimidating yeah like he's you
know even I've never seen anybody more
efficient with their words that guy says
but isn't that what he's known for that
every movie has a lot of signature line
for him it feels like well then you ask
him what's your favorite what's the
favorite line you've ever said he goes I
haven't said it yet that's it fair
enough why haven't we redone at a redo
on Dirty Harry I'm not sure I'm not sure
no it's just I am not be happy to but
but it feels like we revisit everything
and even though that's so iconic Dirty
Harry already heard would be a fun
remake yeah it'd be a worth worthwhile
remake actually so many movies are
remade that shouldn't be like one I know
you're gonna ask that ah oz what was it
they did it was it was deposited a few
years ago with Franco and it was it was
a remit it was a sort of a sort of a
from the viewpoint of Oz yeah yeah James
Franco played Oz right doesn't love that
The Wiz but I love Franco I just didn't
love the movie so much you could be how
about a buddy movie I'm making a buddy
movie you are I made it well who's your
buddy
I've got several buddies in it okay I
got Dax Shepard uh Nick Swardson who you
know well yes you've many stories
probably can't talk about Dan back at
all James Roday Kevin Dillon from from
Olivia Munn is great in the movie all
right yeah what's the gist of this movie
it's about a group of guys that gets
together every year for this thing
called the Buddy games and they compete
in this you know normally it's just you
know ping-pong and what football and
go-kart racing and stuff like that but
this is different because one of the
guys got hurt five years earlier and in
an effort to bring him back into the
fold his mother comes to me and says I
need you to do this for my son and so
that's how it all comes back and we
decide to play for a lot of money so
because we're playing for money I come
up with some pretty outrageous games
that we have to play now you wrote
directed this yeah and what's the name
of it it's called a buddy it is buddy
yeah oh good
and then winds that come out I'm
guessing sometime this summer we haven't
we haven't decided that yet we're still
finishing post-production now I didn't
get a script on that you'd like is it
why is it Sandler cast me in his movies
I would love I would love and you always
say the same thing
after you're done I'll go one time let
me know you like that and like I would
love for one you're old for one Sandler
puts me in every movie Wow not that he
should but he does I mean that's a
friend that is a true friend I would
love for you to do that voiceover at the
beginning of the movie and how long is
the voiceover 45 seconds and I I don't
want to be paid for it I felt like he
was angry for some pay no no I don't
want to be paid but I'll voice this over
so that you start the movie and you got
my voice there that would be amazing
then you know I'm not even kidding you
all right
I if I could be so great I'm gonna smoke
some cigars and have some whiskey before
they do that okay and then it's gonna
sound great in the theater it's gonna
say yeah yeah I'll do whatever you wanna
do cigarettes if you want I'll try to do
that
he's a Josh Duhamel the actor he's
playing in the Pebble Beach pro-am you'd
get nervous in this yeah it's always
nerve-racking playing this tournament
especially if when you're when you're
getting down to the wire and well you
were in the league last year we were
leading it for like I think hole 14 on
Sunday yeah and then of course I do what
I always do and I just you know crumbled
under pressure you ever hit it into the
gallery
several times yeah they think that you
can't believe haven't killed anybody yet
but they think you're a better golfer
than once you are they mate and they
line the fairways like they would do
with phil Mickelson's out there and then
you have to remind them please move back
yeah I almost killed somebody yesterday
liner right into the right into the back
hole shot right straight into the
bleachers they have this uncanny ability
to avoid a hundred-mile-an-hour golf
ball coming out their head it's maybe
maybe they expect that so they were
expecting a stray golf ball from you
they should be um your Vikings now what
do you do how do you feel I feel like it
was a really good year I'm really upset
I'm happy for McLovin because his Eagles
finally got one but you know what I
didn't expect us to play that well this
year I didn't expect that football team
to be as good as they were although I
knew the defense would be good after we
lost Dalvin cook the quarterback
situation but you would have signed up
for a humiliating loss in the NFC title
game if I would have said at the
beginning of the year you're going to
the title game you're not going to the
Super Bowl you're gonna get crushed by
Philadelphia would you have signed up
for that option that you don't know what
this season is going to be I would have
I think I would have signed up for that
because I didn't think I didn't think I
think next year I thought was gonna be
our year
who's your quarterback next year well I
thought foals did such an amazing job
for you guys that you should trade us
wins by the way Josh Dan Josh told me
that he thought the Philadelphia fans
were really nice he went down there was
so sweet to bury they're much nicer
never met a nicer group of people old
ladies were flipping you off it was
followed us to my car it was it was I
was like you beat us 38 to 7 what more
do you want from me did you have Vikings
gira I just had a hat on and they
followed you to your car yeah
threatening label they didn't they
didn't actually do anything did they
recognize you no they didn't care I was
weren't purple they didn't look and they
were drunk wait so they wanted to they
wanted a PC no no they didn't want a
piece me not for real but they let me
know very clearly that I wasn't welcome
there wearing my purple hat by the way
did you time it just so you take off
your hat as the Sun just came
[Laughter]
[Music]
he said I got to be here at 7:14 a.m. I
know he checked the sunrise segment that
works I'm sorry can Tory call yeah he go
he checked the sunset his sunrise and
then that's why he showed him my pocket
McLovin wait can't put that on not gonna
wear your Eagles hat although I do love
Carson Wentz so I do root for your
Eagles just because yeah that's why you
like person won't go yeah I'm a huge
wind fan I think that dude is you know
what if they have a course in winch
story maybe you could play course and
wins ah
I'm Way too old now man yeah I need to
play somebody just hanging on at the end
of their athletic but didn't Kostner
make a career out of that of playing
somebody right at the end of their
career love to I love uh sportsmen you
could be the new Costner sure I'll be
I'll be whoever whoever keeps you know
busy alright you have to go I'm told I
do yeah okay
all right Thank You Josh and we look
forward to the movie and the series is
on USA Network series on USA there's
also a movie called love Simon that
comes out about a month after that
that's pretty great what's the name of
the biggie Tupac
it's called unsolved ok and it's a ten
episode ten episode ten and done yeah
great Thank You Josh
alright alright get out of here thank
you guys for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]